[Music]
I do advise my students to be broad and
open-minded and they're thinking when it
comes to careers I mean basically what
you want is somebody to have a great
career and be happy and you know and so
my advice to students is to not don't do
what's gonna make you the most money or
the most security but do something that
will make you happy whatever that is
well when I got done with graduate
school or when I was finishing graduate
school this was the 1970s and there was
this gas shortage just like a few years
ago and the prices of gas kept going up
so what that meant if you were a
chemical engineer like I was is you'd
get a lot of job offers from oil
companies and pretty much all my
classmates went to oil companies and
worked there and they got very high
paying jobs I did get 20 job interviews
from these companies and I got 20 offers
to but I wasn't very excited about doing
that I remember one interview where they
told me if I could just increase the
yield of this one petrochemical by 0.1
percent that would be worth billions of
dollars and I just wasn't excited about
the impact that that would have and I
kept looking for ways where I guess I
felt I could have more of a of an impact
on the world
well let me give an example of what we
have one thing we did actually when I
was a postdoctoral fellow with Judah
Folkman one of the questions that we
asked was could mount could molecules
exist that could stop blood vessels from
growing in the body a lot of people
didn't believe that that could happen
but my boss dr. time dr. Folkman did and
he hired me and we found that cartilage
was able to block blood vessels this was
done with Henry Brown as well and then
we found but we want to see could we
find an extract in other words were the
real substances that could could stop
blood vessels from growing that might
exist and well there's a lot of things
you have to break up the things into
different parts so first where might a
molecule exists that could stop blood
vessels the answer to that was possibly
cartilage which doesn't have blood
vessels then you have to have a way to
study it and that was very very hard
because blood vessels
but actually grow slowly over time and
we needed what we call as a bio assay
and to develop a bio essay we needed
something that could release these
substances for a very very long time a
little polymer or microsphere or micro
particle so we developed those but none
of those had ever been able to slowly
release molecules that were really big
and the molecules that we thought would
stop blood vessels were really big so we
had to actually then create ways to
release these molecules slowly even
though they were big and release them
for months and that was something people
never thought was possible
but I spent several years working on it
experimenting with different techniques
and eventually I figured out a way to do
it and when we did that we published a
paper in nature showing that for the
first time you could release molecules
of any size from these little micro
particles and then we use that to create
the bioassay and we isolated the first
substances that could stop blood vessels
from growing in the body both of those
discoveries the polymer slow release
systems and the substances that could
stop blood vessels from growing led to
major industries yeah well when I first
gave lectures and on the work we did on
slowly releasing these large molecules
from polymers when we first published
this work pretty much everybody in the
scientific community didn't believe it
and the consequence of that is that I
didn't get any grants my first nine
grants were rejected also when I started
to apply for faculty positions I'm a
chemical engineer and no chemical
engineering department in the world
would hire me I ended up going into a
nutrition department but the problem
there was that the people in that
department didn't think very much of
what I was doing and they basically told
me I should start looking for another
job so it was not very pleasant in the
beginning I think if I had moved away
from it I you know I don't I don't know
what would have happened I mean it's
very hard to to figure out alternative
paths I I think if you give up too
easily
that's not good obviously you don't want
to keep banging your head against the
wall forever so I think there's some
compromises you have to make but I think
if I gave up on something like that
you know maybe I'd give up on other
things that were important to I just
don't know I'm glad I didn't
[Music]